the International Olympic Committee
could decide to award to future Summer
Olympics at the same time this morning
that's big news because that's never
happened before hours ago Los Angeles
Mayor Eric Garcetti led the city's
formal presentation to bring the games
back to the u.s. in 2024 Paris is also
trying to win over IOC members Jamie
yuccas is outside the LA Memorial
Coliseum that's a home of two previous
Olympics and possibly a third is third
time's the charm
Jamie good morning yes I like that gala
third time would be the charm this would
be an unprecedented decision to wear
both cities could end up with the
Olympic Games but then you're looking at
is it 2024 2028 when you wait that long
there's a big impact on budget and of
course venue we're here at the Los
Angeles Coliseum they would need track
installation and plenty of upgrades
before they're ready to host the world
Los Angeles Mayor Eric Garcetti is in a
sprint to the finish line in Switzerland
where the International Olympic
Committee is deciding if it will award
back-to-back games in 2024 and 2028
something it's never done before this
moment requires bold new solutions bold
new thinking and I think Los Angeles is
well poised and the best poised to be
able to answer those questions for the
Olympic movement today but for LA to win
the earlier date the committee will have
to overlook a historic hook 2024 would
mark the hundredth anniversary of Paris
hosting the game's French president
Emmanuel macron said this morning that
Paris is better suited to defend the
game's values of openness and tolerance
which is being challenged by others
everything which made Zeile this Olympic
spirit and which gathers us today in
today's values at risk and I think it's
very consistent with the French DNA it's
a French mission Le Chamber of Commerce
president Gary Tobin I mean is that
ultimately the prize
it's 2024 we never were talking about
2028 until the IOC brought up the
possibility and then we
have to deal with that initially Boston
also got the chance to bid along with
Rome Hamburg and Budapest for 2024 but
all four cities dropped out over cost
and size concerns
David Wharton covers the Olympics for
the Los Angeles Times so the
International Olympic Committee it keeps
touting this as a win-win-win but really
they need to make this happen it's a
deal deal deal they kind of have to give
up something to get one city to wait
both Paris and Los Angeles are hoping to
put on the games without a hefty price
tag
Los Angeles is budgeting more than 5
billion dollars less than half the
estimated cost of the Rio Olympics and a
fraction of the 51 billion dollars Sochi
reportedly spent on the 2014 Winter
Games
if LA doesn't get the games until 2028
there is concern it could lose momentum
no one's ever put on a games where it
was planned 11 years advance how do you
keep that going so that will be a
challenge but for those involved with
bringing the Olympics back to LA it's
game on Los Angeles is so proud of the
1932 and 1984 Olympics and they were
like nothing better than to prove that
they can do it three times in a row now
even if back-to-back games are awarded
Ellie and Paris will still have to
figure out who goes first and that won't
happen until September Noora Noora and
Jamie thank you that's exciting
- great choices - whatever you choose
you like Paris and I do happy with
whatever they just did whatever they
decide